the kids are back to school and when you
take a look around you see the leftover
signs of the summer so what do you do
you take advantage of zero res is their
extended Labor Day sale and you recover
with an amazingly clean home joining me
to tell us more is Ben and Doug McKee
co-owners and operators of Zerorez Las
Vegas welcome guys hey good to see you
Mercedes good to see you now I was so
excited because I thought you brought me
a little gift but this is uh not the
kind of gift I want but it's the kind of
gift that Zerorez will give you by
taking it out of your home tell me a
little bit about what you have here it
is so this little jar is full of all
these goodies it's hair it's all sorts
of nasty stuff that lurks in our carpets
even at home but your vacuum cleaner
can't pull it all out but Zerorez we've
got the technology to get this removed
I'm shaking around twice so that you
don't have to live with it in your
carpets anymore yeah you think that
you're cleaning your carpets like okay
it I vacuumed everything's perfect but
that's still living in there and your ZR
technology can get it out how do you
guys do that it can't and like I said
it's really important to vacuum
regularly but the carpet of rug
Institute recommends getting your
carpets professionally cleaned every six
to 18 months just depending on the
traffic and you know your pet situation
you got going on at home but our Zero
Water technology you can see the results
we can remove the toughest stains as
tough as dirt and nasty stuff hiding in
your carpet get it out without any soaps
or surfactants leave your carpets soft
to the touch and it dries super fast
that's what I love that you're not using
any nasty artificial things in my carpet
let's talk not just about carpets
because we're going to get a little demo
here but let's talk about air ducts I've
been wanting to get my air ducts clean
what have you found in people's air
ducts well you were just telling me my
friend found a bird's nest in hers so
not to level you up with another store
but we've actually removed a dead rat
from our hair before so you don't know
what's hiding in those Ducks get them
professionally cleaned it goes with
making your indoor environment safe
healthy and hygienic it starts with the
carpets ends up in aerodyne let's let's
take a look at what Zerorez can do for
your carpets yeah you do it all not just
carpets not just air ducts hardwood tile
all of it and this is my favorite thing
isn't this incredible I'm so satisfying
I don't get bored with this so right
away you can see the zero res difference
you got dirty carpet you got dual
resified carpet and this is with our gr
water technology it's perfect because if
you have kids or pets you don't have to
worry about that stuff and look we got
three swipes and that is perfectly clean
I mean you could eat off of that carpet
thank you guys so much definitely want
to give Zerorez a call they've got a
deal for you thank you Zerorez for
sponsoring the segment take advantage of
their special two rooms of carpet clean
for only 89 deal plus save 20 off of the
those air ducts you can call
702-840-3333 or go online to
zerorezlasvegas.com for more information
minimum Supply
Las Vegas now will be right